in this video talk about What the fox
plat is how can I hit and then we will
discuss in the temple Let's Get Started
By the way
I Used To This text to graffiti display
This
is also the reason why are a b difficult
to understand the beginning of
information about your data is Pride in
one Blood and My Mothers de media de
intercom trains and pliers can be Found
In The Box plat Will Take a look at Dead
Of A Next few minutes Wat is very
important for using airpods Wat is that
your tetama Stef  Matrixx level
8 and wil household electric blanket
Samsung or the temperature of Gray to
compare
True and more brood of the salary of Men
and Women Now information you can find
In A Bad Blood of the world we go
through Words With Words With
The Box is 11  in the Gates the Range in
Which The Middle 50% Of All values ​​Like
The Lord of the box is the first floor
Tile and your friend It's The Third
Floor Tile therefore 20% of your date
Are
One on 20% of je date are About To  three
again in a box refined Fifty percent of
your this lesson as nice idea As if
People In A Box flat and is with covid-19
Here This Means that percent of the
presidents ayana than 19 Years
yousri is 50 Years This Means that 20%
of the participants  older than 50 Years
and Fifty percent Of Your Pants for
59 years old
and yousri we have So Cold
Range In The Box plat die Solid Line in
that is Damian and the deadline in that
is called Stream for Time With The median is
this what means that have  of the
response a younger than 70 years old and
the other have is al 36 Years
individuel Sint U2 I will grigg's
we have the TC Twiske die TC Twiske
indication lastpoint
in One Point 5 times The winterkwartier
eens What Does that Mean you can see the
Range  die TC Twiske Is Isa de maximum
value of your data from Ed movies
are there for you have outliers die TC
Twiske close-up 2 Point 5 times
If there is no outliers The Witcher is
the maximum value the same is Rudy Lois
k i like the minimum  Y  ou on One Point 5
times the Range
of further old Arcus it s outliers
snowpoint lights out and One Point 5
times The Instagram
de teaser Twister in the Gates The
maximum and minimum values ​​and now we
will Look at an example in order to this
will go  Today that but not you will find
the link in the bio description And then
we Cup iwata into This table
you have dataset where I Fall of a
patient in hospital for stocksy United
We are the weather for the girls at what
time of the day is happened  with Andy
Murray Head What the consequences Of The
Fall Word and finally the age of the
person
from Age weekend tobaccoblat for Age Who
is Yvette maximum value is 90 Years and
Years 6 Years
is 20 is so between
26 stars Twenty Five percent of the
people en  22 and
60% of the people
6095 der Aa the top 20
do you know an OCD Mean is forty five Point
40 and we have media and what is 40
of the Fallen People Ariana Grande
and the other have Is Over There For You
Like You can Change  Straight away  ion Here and
you can see all the Pines and the
Standard deviation
If You click on the title of the Axis
label you can I Change My you can change
the Colors and the font size on the
settings
on the age And For location you get a
Bad  Blood for each Group zo when you can
compare a Different World You Can you
send me the end of a Group and in Which
trains The Cruise
I hope you like the video and the next
time